before i went into care i'd say anyone
who knew me would say i was so innocent
i still think if i hadn't gone into care
i wouldn't have seen half of things i've
seen i wouldn't have gone missing or got
off to random houses with dangerous men
you just always wonder why you're not
good enough to stay there and
it'll always be in the back of my mind
like why weren't i good enough just to
why didn't they want me
this story happens too often but is
rarely told amber spent her teenage
years bouncing through the care system
although care is the wrong word for it
first she was placed with a foster
family 30 miles away from her home in
hull but never felt she belonged
they was going away on holiday and
because i was running away more and more
often they said basically like we don't
want you to come on holiday so then they
put me
in a rest by in beverly
um
and i didn't stay there and then from
there that's when i was running away
like for longer periods and more often
and so began a journey into increasing
isolation eight foster placements later
age 14 amber was deemed the most at-risk
child in the area posing the question
was she safer at home she was eventually
sent 120 miles away to a residential
home the independent review of
children's social care calls for a
revolution in family help that could
keep children out of care amber's mother
who doesn't want to be on camera says
she and her daughter were desperate not
to be separated
my mum and everybody begged her and i
begged him for like psychological help
for amber because she was really going
through it and and then
embarrassingly she upset that her father
had
gone and left the family home yeah what
were they worried about you were they
worried about um with the drugs alcohol
are the accused of it and i asked for a
drug test i've never given one
one reason given was concerns of
parental neglect
but is the current system a form of
state neglect
amber became friends with other
vulnerable girls such as millie not her
real name who went missing from care 280
times over a three year period when he
went missing where would you stay
um
just random peoples really like not just
people i'd met people i'd talk to like
on facebook and stuff but just
i just want keeping myself safe
millie met amber on social media they
ran away together and were abused by a
gang of men in shrewsbury who plied them
with alcohol
he'd put his hand over my mouth and i
was crying i was saying no no no but
obviously he was
he was a lot bigger than me i mean i was
young
and and then he
forced me to sleep with him
amber was also raped by other men at the
flat both girls spoke to the police
they took pictures of my neck and
also i told him what i knew
but
no one no one cared like no one was
interested at all
what what what makes you say that
like
what was more just viewed as like
runaways and
like just bad people rather than
like victims of csa
amber changed massively changed and
and it was so worrying because nobody
had listened nobody would do anything
like all the police was bothered about
was taking her back to where she needed
to be yeah and all social services was
bothered about was getting her back to
where she needed to be and that was it
they just skipped over it all they hid
it all
west mercier police say they did
investigate but had insufficient
evidence for prosecution
meanwhile amber says staff at the care
home she kept running away from bribed
her to lie to the ofsted inspectors
the ofsted report um
i wanted a new car at the time and they
said that if i spoke well and did what i
did then they'd give me
money
for a new car
amber often ran away back to her mother
in hull but wasn't allowed to stay and
next she was moved even further away to
a home that specialised in child sexual
exploitation
they all specialized in cse so every
single gallon that had been exploited so
it was kind of to me i realized quite
quickly that all they wanted to do was
just run away and go meet men because
that's what they was all normal to
yeah but i've seen with my stuff it was
all quite fresh with what happened to me
so i didn't
want to but when people are like saying
come on come on you're quite influenced
to go yeah but the home itself it was
just shocking like those staff were just
no one really spoke to yeah they just
did what they did when it says it's
specialist with cs for cse i mean what
specialist help was it offering i think
the only thing i specialized in is girls
was in there that had cse other than
that there was no specialist care
within days she'd run away with other
girls from the home to south london here
she was introduced to hard drugs and was
again raped this time by men in criminal
gangs over a two and a half year period
amber went missing 106 times she was
eventually moved to a secure unit which
she says was like a prison a social
services report explained the move
and i read the first page and i just
started crying i couldn't even read it
just the horrific sexual abuse knives
drugs alcohol
many many men just i wouldn't call them
men just animals
no one asked no one asked me if i was
okay what had happened no one asked me
so
i think at the time they just felt out
of sight out of mind because i was
locked up in a secure unit like they had
no
no i'm not going to tell anyone i'm not
going to speak out because no one will
listen
did you feel like you were the criminal
that you'd done
you were doing time
yeah
i just thought why am i here when
they're all walking the streets
yeah
so you essentially gone there from being
multiply raped yeah you were being
locked up yeah
parents are powerless because
as far as they're concerned we've lost
our kids so you you just be quiet now
you know you can't say anything but
we've got the care order and
yeah and that's the way it seems to be
at the minute so you feel like the
social services system is essentially
pushing her into the clutches of these
of these men yeah
yeah
people look down on you
i've realized that
and the police they just think well
she's in care so she's naughty
the top 10 child care providers made 300
million pounds in profit last year the
children's social care review suggests a
windfall tax on them to help pay for
intensive help for families in crisis to
try to keep them together if the
recommendations are followed the report
authors claim in 10 years it would keep
30 000 children out of the care system
jason farrell sky news